scum resumes here a bad time is here for
another fabulous obsession
all right so who should we start with
let's go with me Megan facts
Megan facts has it had great legs
Hollywood super stache super rich they
wait yeah yeah ah and there there was
something after you make it
oh gosh alright then oh wow Meghan you
look fabulous today I must say there is
something wrong with me I can't tell you
what it is let's go to Twitter and see
what you think your reactions
I don't know before active not fabulous
fabulous at Samba heavy had Tina not
there
let's see what we can do with you let's
just start doing some minor changes and
Photoshop magic will and yeah we're done
just this tiny touch-up effects I didn't
need to work a lot much with it it's a
standard standard stuff in this industry
it's pretty much perfect Oh Mel Gibson
you're so fine you're so fine you blow
yourself and you Mel Gibson I'm such a
big fan I love you Valda Matisse at you
very much angry now your slender man
come on make up your mind Manny that's
pretty ice all the mark could be a model
technically I mean I've seen worse let's
just put it that way
kanya sorry oh my god this is so
scandalous
I can't believe Kanye would cheat on his
girlfriend man the media's are gonna
post everything about this I'm still
amazed how pretty Voldemort is I mean
who can blame Kanye for giving in to the
temptation Oh Dre yousa fine I have to
do this I know I'd done it before but
it's gonna be hot it's been awoken oh
that's a night bid you got that Drake
tray wow you're big you're my new best
friend let's finish with good old
Kirsten that let's migraines are an
actual vampire Kirsten I trusted you
Cheston why did you do it
why did you do it Katie I like how she
hasn't one nostril why not you know what
why not now of course if you're a
vampire you need alright I think that's
pretty good
and I think we're done for today oh yeah
I love making these episodes it's so I
love [ __ ] wrong with Photoshop I
don't know if you can town go ahead and
leave a like if you enjoy watching
breaths hit the sky come read today and
I will see you in the next episode or
whatever I make so stay awesome brothers
love you